[Music]
5 25 on your Finally Friday what's
driving you crazy well this morning we
have a different kind of Hoover Dam
heads up
we told you that The Pedestrian part of
the bypass bridge is closing for about a
week starting July 17th for maintenance
and repairs that's a week from this
coming Monday not affecting traffic but
here's that other heads up that's all
about cars coming and going from that
magnificent bridge that maybe we've
started to take for granted but starting
next Monday July 10th the Nevada
Department of Transportation starts a
nearly three week long project that's
going to have the two miles leading up
to and coming from the bridge reduced to
one lane at a time 24 7 except for no
work on weekends
obviously if your travels don't take
anywhere near the bridge you're not
affected however we want you to tell
anyone you know who may be coming or
going over the next few weeks to check
the online version of this story on our
website 8newsnow.com click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone you
can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com